[Music]
thank you very much for joining us the
international criminal court has opened
an investigation into suspected war
crimes
and crimes against humanity committed by
israel in the occupied palestinian
territory
palestinians who joined the icc in 2015
have
asked the court to look into israeli
military actions in the gaza strip in
2014.
they also want the court to investigate
israel's construction
of illegal settlements in the occupied
west bank
and east jerusalem now the icc says it
will also look into the actions of
gaza-based hamas and other palestinian
groups
during the conflict while palestine's
foreign minister has welcomed
the investigation in a statement he said
this
is a long-awaited step that serves
palestine's tireless pursuit
of justice and accountability which are
indispensable pillars of the peace the
palestinian people
seek and deserve well we have two
reporters standing by to cover the story
for us nida ibrahim is in
occupied west bank and harry fossett is
in jerusalem
for us nida let's uh start with you a
long-awaited decision by the icc it's
taken years
to come to this decision what is the
reaction first from palestinians
of course a wide welcoming remarks from
many palestinian officials
and ngos that have been working with the
palestinian authority
on advancing this issue in the
international criminal court
this is the main point that palestinians
were hoping to get to since the
palestinians have
joined the sign the rome statute in
2015 and some even say that this is the
reason why the palestinian authority
has seeked its diplomatic and
international
approach at the u.n security council
with the hopes to get a full membership
of course this didn't happen they got a
non-member state status via
the general assembly which had allowed
them to go forward
and join the rome statute and ask the
icc to investigate crimes now
one of the main issues that the
palestinians hope that the icc would
investigate
is the illegal israeli settlement on the
ground they hope that the icc's
prosecutor
would look into this as the main
violation of international law
and they believe that this has been a
policy by
the israeli authority it's not just a
war crime here or there
uh they believe that the foreign
ministry has released the statement as
you mentioned and they say that this
has been continuing and these work
crimes are ongoing which is why they
want the icc to investigate and
conclude its investigation urgently
nida the chief prosecutor of the icc
fatou bensouda
named the israeli army of course but
armed palestinian groups also such as
hamas as possible perpetrators of these
war crimes
what will be the reaction there from
these armed palestinian groups
especially at a time when different
palestinian factions have
tried to unite and bring about more
unity within palestine
when the icc's prosecutor said that she
believes that there are grounds for
opening an investigation that was
late in 2019 we seek the reaction from
the palestinian
factions including hamas and they have
said that they are
welcoming that they are they want to
have
an investigation by the international
criminal court
the palestinian factions are arguing and
they have been arguing for years now
that their
part that their armed resistance is part
of their
legal uh opposition and legal resistance
against the illegal israeli occupation
and this is why they hope that the icc
would focus
on the israeli crimes when it comes to
the gaza wars
but also and most importantly the
ongoing
continuous illegal settlement
construction in the occupied west bank
nida ibrahim in ramallah in the occupied
west bank thank you very much let's now
get the view
the uh view uh from israel harry foster
is in west jerusalem forest this is a
move harry that's always been
opposed by israel any early reactions
uh nothing that we've seen so far to
this precise step
but uh as nila was just just talking
about there was this decision
just last month by the panel of judges
to say that the uh the criteria had been
met for this to be
an investigation that could go forward
and at that point we heard
a very strong denunciation from the
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
of the endeavour saying that it was pure
anti-semitism
accusing the icc of being a politicized
institution
of course he worked very closely in
concert with the trump administration
to try to uh head this off uh the trump
administration issuing sanctions
against specific members of the
international criminal court that's
something that the bite administration
has been looking to unpick but the new
president biden
has also said through his officials
that he views this uh as something that
shouldn't go ahead
this investigation uh there's also been
comment from
prime minister benjamin netanyahu's uh
coalition partner
and shortly election rival benny gans
the defense minister
he was asked about this on tuesday
and he was saying that he was judging
himself as one of hundreds of people
who could be investigated and
potentially prosecuted
under this investigation of course the
icc uh investigates individuals
not states and he said that members of
the israeli military
uh would be protected and that he was at
that stage
hoping to try to head off this
investigation going forward now of
course we know
that it is going forward and as far as
israel is concerned
uh they challenge the legitimacy of the
process
thank you harry for that harry fossett
live for us today in west jerusalem
let's discuss all this further now with
ambassador
omar awa dalla who's head of the united
nations and human rights department at
the
palestinian ministry of foreign affairs
he's via skype from ramallah thank you
very much ambassador
for being with us says harry foster our
correspondent said there
the icc investigates individuals in this
case and not a state and already the
israeli prime minister
had said has said that he would protect
individuals within israel who are
suspected of these war crimes so
what is your reaction first to this icc
decision do you think it can achieve
justice definitely we believe that
the prosecutor uh did what she has with
its
obligation and under its mandate that's
why we saw it as a
victory for international law and
justice and that's why we welcome
the decision by the prosecutor to
investigate
the war crimes that committed committed
in the occupied palestinian territory
including east jerusalem we understand
that netanyahu and his
war criminal criminals they should be
afraid now from this
important body from this important stand
by the international criminal court this
as you say is about investigating war
crimes it's not necessarily about
determining
other issues in this conflict issues
like statehood and so on
so how does it help palestinians
it was very clear that there is nothing
to do with the issue of statehood and
that question was resolved actually
by the decision by the trial chamber
that
the issue of statehood is not the thing
that they are
looking in they are looking about the
jurisdiction of the international
criminal court and now
by the decision of opening the
investigation it's very clear that there
is
a important and territorial jurisdiction
of the international criminal court
where they can investigate war crimes
and crimes against
humanity that means that the era of
immunity for the israeli
officials is coming to an end and
within within the mandate of the
international criminal court
right it's not just israel however as
we've said palestinian factions
including hamas
are also likely to be investigated here
and the next step
in this will be to determine whether
israel or palestinian authorities have
investigations themselves and to assess
those so
how much cooperation can we expect from
the palestinian factions
we are ready uh we already we all uh
welcome the decision by the prosecutor
and before that we welcome the decision
by the british
chamber all the factions and the
government of the state of palestine we
all welcome this
decision and we are ready to cooperate
to coordinate with the
office of the prosecutor or the
investigator the investigators and
or any other advisors by the
international criminal court we will be
ready to cooperate and work closely with
the international criminal court
but we don't believe that israel is
going to investigate because
it is a policy it's a widespread and
systematic
policy of aggression against the
palestinian people
and crimes against the palestinian
people we don't believe
that there is any kind of investigation
in the israeli colonial regime and the
settlement regime
it's a governmental policy and a state
policy
indeed israel has already indicated at
least the prime minister has indicated
that it
didn't want to cooperate with this
investigation let me ask you a final
question ambassador
and this is about palestinian unity this
is coming at a time when
the various palestinian factions have
been trying to unite ahead of
uh elections that are coming up soon are
you concerned
that any investigation and its result a
conclusion
if it found let's say palestinian
factions also
guilty of war crimes would hamper these
efforts to bring about
unity we don't think that
as we said that all the factions the
factions and the government
they will come this decision and we are
going to coordinate we believe that our
unity is is a major and a better
issue in our march to freedom that's why
none the investigation or any other
issue can stop
this this process toward reconciliation
and having a unity between uh west bank
including jerusalem and gaza ambassador
thank you very much for talking to us
about this thank you for bring
giving us your reaction ambassador omar
award is head of
the united nations and human rights
department at the palestinian foreign
ministry